[Music]
we're with Sir Robin whales the elected
mayor of the Houma where the Olympics
were held tell us please sir Robin what
kind of event is this and why it is that
you support kids in chess we believe the
most important things for cleanses
develop resilience to do that you give
them lots of opportunities for different
things so we teach them to play musical
instrument we get them into dancer and
duendes for weather and chess is such a
good thing
generally for kids trying to encourage
them to player improve concentration
improver but thank you process this is a
great game and if some of those kids get
excited by it
and have some idea that themselves
through it well then for us that that's
the practice of it so it's to give kids
opportunities and noise it enjoy it let
them go and play some more if someone is
really young and then you might let them
take a draw I don't mind too much but if
they're old enough to know that they
probably should lose then I think it's
unfair to them to offer them a draw
because then they know you're giving it
to them so finally I think the kids who
would appreciate the draw the most are
the ones I don't give it to it and the
youngest ones who probably don't realize
the value I might offer it but they tend
to be the ones that turn it down and
then you're blushing
so it's unreliable I've offered Ross to
kids and then they turn it down - what
did you feel like when you heard you
were going to play against the world
champion
funded in a way by a special I thought
that it was amazing and I was going to
be a great experience I'm nervous
because I've never faced like the world
champion or anyone who's this famous I
was just like do you think that you have
a chance of winning the game what would
you do if you actually won the game I
would be amazed ow
I'll say good game and I'll just tell my
mom and dad
[Music]
I would give send away and I'm good
[Music]